tu ne l'implique pas dans ça tu
m'implique dans ça en ne disant pas que tu
dois la sortir d'ici la renvoyer chez elle
bien qu'est-ce que tu vas dire à chaerephon
que je suis content que les gens dangereux se
rassemblent tu ne peux pas être ici si tu l'as dit  moi
qui tu étais vraiment je plaisante la souris
j'ai prêté serment je ne pouvais pas te le dire à
moins que nous soyons mariés ne ferait pas de mal
c'est pourquoi tu voulais m'épouser pour
que tu sois heureux tu pourrais dire à quelqu'un que
tu veux bien sûr pas toi  tu m'as menti
pendant trois ans et tu étais doué pour ça
je pense que ça t'a vraiment plu on peut
avoir une minute s'il te plait non tu peux je
voudrais parler à la justice géopolitique ce n'est
pas une thérapie de couple dois je vraiment
te rappeler ce qui est en jeu ici  jack,
il y a un scénario très réel ici où
nous ne nous en sortons pas vivants, aucun de nous
n'a vraiment besoin de votre dîner, lâchez-moi par les
nerfs du vétérinaire ici